foreign
let's go to Andrew in Atlanta Georgia
home of the Braves at lost what's up
Andrew
hey Dr John how are you doing just
taking my digs in before the Astros uh
they're not looking great right now so
what's up man
a weird one so
you've got hey you called the right show
you called the right show right
so um back in September we went on a
Disney trip with the whole family it was
a paid for Thing by my mother-in-law oh
gosh I'll give you a couple Red Flags uh
we were all staying in the same Airbnb
and you all have kids
yes okay there were two two were mine
and my wife's and the other two are my
sister-in-laws
um and they're all between the ages of
four and seven
so what could possibly go wrong Awesome
everything uh
[Laughter]
part of the trip was they wanted us all
to ride together down which my wife
refused she's like no we're driving
separate hey you married well okay
continue
yeah she's pretty smart
um so we get down there and everything's
kind of going okay
um and then we have an issue one night
um my sister-in-law loves to go from
zero to a hundred for nothing like
absolutely nothing I'm not sure scream
at my mother-in-law over stupid stuff at
Christmas you know we're trying to have
a nice time and we're getting screamed
at because the potatoes weren't the way
she wanted or whatever right
um it's just a normal thing to watch and
it's um you know I've kept my mouth shut
been married for eight years kept my
mouth shut right
um my wife and her go back and forth
over a toy of all things
which my wife was just trying to say we
need to find you know our son's version
of this because he had you know her
son's version of that and she was like
scream bloody murder kids were done they
wanted to go home my wife was done she
wanted to go home I told myself just
wait let's calm down high tension right
trying to be The Optimist high tension
I'll just calm down if she does it again
let me handle it like she's a bully she
won't let you talk any say anything you
know when you're trying to express
whatever it is you're trying to say in
the moment like let me deal with it I've
been dealing with those for my whole
life I've got this
well the next evening she starts it
again but she's starting to bad mouth my
wife in front of my kids while we're at
the pool like we're in the pool there's
a pool in the back of the Airbnb they're
all sitting on the patio and um she
starts saying something so I just looked
at her and I said I wouldn't say
anything
and she just looked across the patio at
me and she was like excuse me
and I was like I wouldn't I wouldn't say
anything you know
just telling you I wouldn't start she's
like she's like I wouldn't start I was
like do you want to do this right now
and she said yeah I want to do this
right now so I called her a bully
and she lost it she absolutely lost it
screaming out there all kinds of
obscenities freaking the Freak Out the
kids are all stunned they're all in the
pool they're all stunned and um you know
she storms in
and I'm just like okay that was uh
interesting reaction
well her six foot four 350 to 400 pound
boyfriend steps out of the house oh yeah
yeah so I'm sitting in the corner of the
patio there's a table in front of me and
now he is pulling up a chair right in
front of me dude this is when you sweep
the leg did you not watch Karate Kid One
well he was sitting he was a chair I was
in a chair that's fair I'm all about
de-escalating you know and but he comes
up he gets right in my face and he says
you want to see a bully
and I burst out laughing I burst out
laughing I look over at my mother-in-law
and I'm like is this guy kidding like
are we serious uh by now my wife had
re-entered you know the patio and um she
was coming to get the kids after she
started screaming and she saw what was
going on she tried to
um you know put herself between me and
him and kind of push him back and he
stood up and she's telling him yeah the
way you know we're not scared of you
we're leaving get out of our way
um she pushes the table out of the way
and when she does that he reaches out
and pulls true out from under me
um I stand up but he puts me in a
headlock
so I'm still sitting there trying to
de-escalate
um I'm waiting to see what happens it's
not a tight headlock so I don't feel
scared or intimidated or anything at the
moment yet
and finally lets me go we pack all of
our stuff we go get our hotel we leave
the house okay you fast forwarded me too
right now how can I help you right now
so right now so after that happens uh
the in-laws
sent my wife's crazy text about how she
needs to deal with her hatred and her
heart and they never even got to thank
you for the trip and all this stuff this
is the night this all happened that we
got in the hotel sure
um and uh Bermuda right now I can help
you right now
so you know we have not communicated
with them since this happened absolutely
um
everybody's opted out
right they chose the other side they
went to Disney and had fun the next day
with this guy that handled their
son-in-law
um so going into the holidays my you
know hey we already know that's not
happening
um so hey
how do we communicate to our kids like
when they start asking hey when are we
going to their house and stuff like hey
that's that's not happening
um and B what's our best foot forward
and I mean they've opted out but should
we say something like hey you were wrong
for this or should we just let it go no
I mean okay so
number one I mean the way you told the
story you had some bravado You Waltz in
I I've been handling this my whole life
I got this and then you didn't
and so part of me you invited it in
you entered into a conflict that wasn't
yours between two sisters
and it ended poorly okay and so I think
there's something to be learned about if
you're gonna say you better recognize
then you might get recognized right and
then the second thing is
it went sideways and you all left you
should have left
and it's devastating when we can't you
can't talk something out right it's
devastating when
um parents don't say hey that is
unacceptable and
your in-laws are clearly
trying to prop up a picture of a happy
family
and they're willing to put thousands and
thousands of dollars towards this
picture it's a myth it's a fantasy
for whatever reason my guess is they
know what a train wreck your
sister-in-law is
they probably have problems with you and
they're trying to recreate a Norman
Rockwell painting in real life and it's
not real and so when somebody walks out
of the picture regardless of why they
left they are the bad guy because they
left the picture
and so the next day everybody woke up
the sun came up and you all were the
ones that were gone so y'all are the
easy bad guys okay here's why that
doesn't matter
y'all left you did the right thing
I would not have talked to them since
then
I would have let them if they choose to
re-engage us great but
we put our boundaries up and we're out
and when the kids ask
you say remember Aunt so and so when she
was screaming and yelling remember when
her big boyfriend
um put his hands on Dad we only go
places where it's safe for the whole
family and so we're not gonna go there
that's it that is it and we're not gonna
we don't have to have a bunch of other
conversations my promise to you is the
kids are going to think way less of this
than you all are
and my also promise is for your wife
this isn't this is the world she grew up
in
and so she's probably been going back
and saying she's sorry and fixing the
the
family dysregulation for a long time and
it's easy to walk out in the heat of a
moment but as time goes on it's like
well you know and dad was and mom was
sister was really and so that's probably
been her whole life
and so you are gonna have to decide to
hold firm on this and choose safety and
choose joy and choose laughter right
holidays are too short man they're too
precious
I I guess here's what I'm struggling
with one
I mean you stepped into it and it
happened
two I don't know
I don't know what you're lamenting or
sad about or did you did you you took a
stand
and nobody stood with you I guess is the
challenge here but I don't know what
you're upset about it seems like it's
all played out perfectly you don't have
to be around these in-laws who aren't
seeing the world clearly and you don't
have to be around an unsafe
sister-in-law and her boyfriend like I
don't know what you're upset about
well you know there's a
you know reconciliation and you know
like you can't right I'm not you cannot
reconcile with people who don't want to
be reconciled with
so we should wait for them to come
around and realize they were kind of
being stupid in the in the moment rather
than point out to them don't put yeah
what last time you pointed out things
how did that end it ended with you in
the armpit of a 400 pound man
all right like they have no interest in
seeing
anything other than their perspective
yes you pointing this things out will
not help the situation at all
you choosing
to not carry their bricks around you
choosing to find joy
you choosing to make the best of a
holiday season maybe the first one in
eight years it's going to be one of
peace and not anger and not accelerated
heart rates and you dancing around and
trying not to set off sister-in-law and
trying to make sure your wife is a maybe
for the first time
y'all just get a hotel with a pool and
let your kids Remember the Time Santa
showed up at the hotel and just have a
good three-day weekend you know what I
mean reimagine the whole thing and and
and have that be something beautiful and
fun not lamenting
got it does that make sense
yeah it is an utter waste of your time
to try to come up with the right word I
mean literally think through this
through is there something you're gonna
say your sister-in-law is going to be
like no way I never thought of that
thanks Andrew like no it's never gonna
happen you know what I mean or like uh
her giant boyfriend is gonna be like hey
man listen when you call my girlfriend a
bully
you're right she's rude and I'm we're
going to counseling is that gonna happen
no it's not gonna happen he did what
he's what boyfriends do right and and so
on so on down the line it's here's what
it it feels disorienting because you
feel powerless you can't solve this
problem and as you said at the very
beginning of the call you have a history
of solving these type of problems of
waiting in being the calm person in the
storm saying the right thing and
everyone's like you're right and this is
one you can't solve and so that means
you have to dust your sandals off as the
great Jay-Z says brush your shoulders
off and walk on man
right
you don't sound like you believe me well
no so I just the other thing to you know
my wife my wife sees a therapist every
week and uh has been unpacking this too
and you know there's a codependent
relationship there that she recognizes
and she's with her mom and she's you
know been dissecting that but
you know the part part of the hard thing
too is like you know she feels sometimes
like when she leaves work she wants to
call her mom and she wants to absolutely
absolutely it's not out of hey I have
joy in this it's out of that
relationship they have it's no it's it's
a codependency in its in its root form
is an addiction it's a love addiction as
the great PM Melody says
she's addicted to the chemicals she gets
when she creates a fantasy and tries to
uphold her side of it
and occasionally her mom is really kind
and occasionally her mom is funny and
tells her a hilarious story and then she
falls under the illusion that's my real
mom there she is I just need to do more
of this so that real mom stays out more
and then real mom actually shows up
and real mom is dysfunctional and real
mom is predatory and real mom uses your
wife as a prop in her play
all the while your daughter's asking
herself the same question she's been
asking since she was a little girl what
is it what's so bad about me what's
wrong with me
that mommy won't fully connect with me
and that's not a question kids need to
ask that's the adult question
and so yes it's totally natural for your
wife to just want to pick up the phone
and call her mom
totally natural
it's totally natural for your wife to be
heartbroken and weep over the holidays
season this year
totally normal that's just grief the gap
between what we wanted and what we hoped
for and what reality gave us
that's where y'all are
and then you have to ask yourself like
many callers on this show like I have to
ask myself
what are we gonna do next are we gonna
sit and wallow in this
or are we going to choose Joy
are we going to construct something new
that's going to be fun and we're going
to give our kids a wild great time we
get to pick we get to pick
and one like for me at my house we're
gonna choose Joy every single time
sorry man
brush your shoulders off brother move on
to the next